traffic related deaths are still on the
rise across las vegas specifically those
involving motorcycles madison kimbrough
spoke with a driver who shared a
dangerous video of a group going against
a red light in the west valley she joins
us live near rampart and summerlin
parkway right where this happened
madison
yeah it's pretty shocking as the man who
took the video was teaching his teenage
daughter how to drive right here on
rampart and summerlin parkway
it's happening on saturday night you can
see the bikers have the right-of-way but
then as the light turns red these riders
continue to ride through brett kavanaugh
the man who shot this video is an avid
writer himself and says this kind of
behavior is what gives motorcycle riders
a bad name a lot of people who drive
cars and don't drive motorcycles
don't have respect for motorcycle riders
and first thing in my mind was this is
part of the reason why you know they're
just setting a bad example
they blocked every vehicle in the
intersection that had the right way it
concerns me
having a 15 year old who's going to be
getting a driver's license soon that
she's going to be out on the road with
people that drive that way just recently
a motorcyclist was killed after drifting
out of their lane and hitting a median
near the strip that death marked the
118th traffic related fatality in
metro's jurisdiction far surpassing
years prior
and according to the office of traffic
safety there has been over a 50 percent
increase in the amount of motorcyclists
hit and killed this year reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now